[Music]
once upon a time South America lived
harmoniously alongside Africa until a
crack in the earth drove the two
continents apart this breakup began
about 200 million years ago during the
separation of the supercontinent known
as Pangaea their proximity back then
explains why the same plant fossils and
reptile fossils like the mezzo Saurus
can be found on the south american east
coast and african west coast
however this evidence does not account
for how the continents moved apart for
that we'll need to take a close look at
the earth below our feet though you may
not realize it the ground below you is
traveling across the earth at a rate of
about 10 centimeters per year or the
speed at which your fingernails grow
this is due to plate tectonics or the
large-scale movement of Earth's
continents the motion occurs within the
top two layers of the Earth's mantle the
lithosphere and asthenosphere the
lithosphere which includes the crust and
uppermost mantle comprises the land
around you beneath the lithosphere is
the asthenosphere the highly viscous but
solid rock portion of the upper mantle
it's between 80 and 200 kilometres below
the earth's surface
while the asthenosphere wraps around the
Earth's core as one connected region the
lithosphere is separated on top into
tectonic plates there are seven primary
tectonic plates that compose the shape
of the planet we know today like the
other smaller tectonic plates the
primary plates are about 100 kilometers
thick and are composed of one or two
layers continental crust and oceanic
crust continental crust forms the
continents and areas of shallow water
close to their Shores
whereas oceanic crust forms the ocean
basins the transition from the granitic
continental crust to the basaltic
oceanic crust occurs beyond the
continental shelf in which the shore
suddenly slopes down towards the ocean
floor the South American plate is an
example of a tectonic plate made of two
crusts the continents we know from
today's map and a large region of the
Atlantic Ocean around it
collectively comprising the lithosphere
these plates are brittle ER and stiffer
than the heated malleable layer of the
asthenosphere below because of this the
tectonic plates float on top of this
layer independently of one another the
speed and direction in which these
tectonic plates move depends on the
temperature and pressure of the
asthenosphere below scientists are still
trying to nail down the driving forces
behind this movement with some theories
pointing towards mantle convection while
others are examining the influence of
the Earth's rotation and gravitational
pull though the mechanics have not been
sorted out the scientific community
agrees that our tectonic plates are
moving and have been for billions of
years because these plates move
independently a fair amount of pushing
and pulling between the plates occurs
the first type of interaction is a
divergent boundary in which two plates
move away from one another we see this
in the mid-atlantic ridge between South
America and Africa the next interaction
is when two plates collide known as a
convergent boundary in this instance the
land is pushed upward to form large
mountain ranges like the Himalayas in
fact the Indian plate is still colliding
with the Eurasian Plate which is why
Mount Everest grows one centimetre per
year finally there's the transform
boundaries where two plates scrape past
one another the grinding of the
transform boundary leads to many
earthquakes which is what happens in the
810 mile long San Andreas Fault
the moving earth is unstoppable and
while a shift of 10 centimeters per year
may not seem like a lot over millions of
years our planet will continue to
dramatically change mountains will rise
shorelines will recede islands will pop
up in fact one projected map shows the
cities of Los Angeles and San Francisco
on top of each other
maybe South America and Africa will come
together again - only time will tell